.
>> Tucker: THANKS SO MUCH FOR
THAT.
THIS IS A CABLE NEWS SHOW, WE
NEVER PRETEND WE ARE AN
INTERNATIONAL FEMINIST
ORGANIZATION, BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN WE DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
FATE OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
WE DO CARE AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE BEEN MONITORING THE
SITUATION IN CONGRESSMAN
ERIC SWALWELL'S OFFICE, YOU
REMEMBER A LONG TIME AFFAIR WITH
A CHINESE SPY THAT INCLUDED
PERSONAL BEHAVIOR
EUPHEMISTICALLY DESCRIBED AS
STOMACH TURNING AND UNNATURAL.
WE WILL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
SO THE SPY GIRLFRIEND HAS SINCE
FLED BACK TO CHINA AHEAD OF THE
DOJ, BUT ERIC SWALWELL HIMSELF
IS AT LARGE TONIGHT IN
WASHINGTON AND CALIFORNIA, WE'VE
BEEN KEEPING TABS ON HIM BECAUSE
WE THINK IT'S ARE DIRTY.
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT HIS EFFORTS TO
FIND YOUNG WOMEN WHO MIGHT BE
WILLING TO "EXPAND HIS BRAND"
WHATEVER THAT MEANS, JUST DAYS
TO LIVE AND SAYING THE WORDS
MAKES THE HAIR ON HER ARM STAND
UP.
HE HAS BEEN CAUGHT ADVERTISING
FOR STILL MORE WOMEN.
HIS OFFICE HAS POSTED "JOG
LISTING" ON CRAIGSLIST NOTING
THAT YOUNG WOMEN ARE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGED TO JOIN HIM TO MANAGE
HIS AGENDA."
VERBATIM QUOTE.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE YOUR DAUGHTER
MANAGING ERIC SWALWELL'S AGENDA?
HOW HIS BEHAVIOR LIKE THIS
ALLOWED IN 2021 AND THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS?
WHERE'S NANCY PELOSI?
IF THIS WAS HAPPENING IN
KANDAHAR, CNN WOULD BE DEMANDING
THAT THESE AGENDA MANAGERS
RECEIVE IMMEDIATELY ASYLUM FOR
THEIR ON SAFETY.
THIS IS A PRESSING HUMAN RIGHTS
CRISIS, BUT BECAUSE
ERIC SWALWELL IS DOING IT,